it says the China situation because you
have many critics you have many
criticisms and not just fictional ones
but you have ones that are very valid
criticism what went on in China we put a
ton of effort into
taking overtime in China violence
erupted at the world's largest iPhone
Factory it sounds easy to see people in
the audience this is actually hard
because it's complex because some people
work want to work a lot as hundreds of
workers fought with authorities over a
benefits dispute and covid-19
restrictions we're measuring working
hours for 700 000 people
and so we're micromanaging that
and we're showing a level of care that I
don't think I don't see in in other
places
as you've probably heard already Apple
isn't having the best time right now in
China and from what I'm about to show
you in this video it's pretty clear that
they are breaking up the story of Apple
in China goes way back many years and
even decades ago and today most of the
iPhones being produced are produced in
China and no matter how you spin it the
main reason is for apple to save money
on labor of course because Chinese labor
is a lot less expensive than U.S labor
just look at the story of this NYU
student who spent six weeks working
undercover in an iPhone Factory he spent
12 hours a day putting in one screw into
an iPhone non-stop that's all he did he
mentioned that most of the workers there
can't actually afford a new iPhone he
mentioned being yelled at in trial
productions being the worst almost like
torture and he said that six weeks on
the assembly line only paid about
450 dollars not even enough to buy an
iPhone and that's even worth working six
days a week only getting Sundays off and
if you're wondering about the cost
difference between a US worker and a
Chinese worker check out this clip from
10 years ago while the average worker
building Electronics in the US today
makes over 23 dollars an hour and works
41 hours a week most of the people at
Foxconn earn just over two dollars an
hour and strive for a 60 hour work week
now of course that was 10 years ago so
the wages are a little bit different
these days but the point is that apple
is saving a ton of money with Chinese
workers working more hours and making
over 10 times less than a US worker so
because of all of that Apple has been
enjoying some steep profit Mar Origins
on their iPhones for many many years
with great success but then came Trump
he came into the office and he put a lot
of blame on China which kick-started the
trade war with sanctions on products
from China which impacted both the
Chinese economy and even the U.S economy
as well and it had a lot of negative
impacts on companies specifically
putting a lot of pressure on Apple
because Apple relies on China more than
pretty much any other company out here
in the states and here's where it got
really tricky for Apple the Trump
imposed Tariff of 25 on electronic Goods
could mean that the price of the iPhone
10s would have went up by a hundred and
sixty dollars so this could have hit
Apple massively and just looking at a
stat from 2019 92 percent of Apple
products made in China could face
tariffs by the end of that year so Apple
started to get a little bit clever and
it got to work specifically with the Mac
Pro they announced that Apple's new Mac
Pro would be made in Texas yes made in
the USA and apparently Tim Cook even
gave the first Mac Pro in production to
Trump of course he was sucking up to him
trying to make friends trying to make a
deal and then guess what happened Apple
dodged the iPhone tariff after Trump
confirmed the trade deal agreement with
China Apple barely got around it and I
think it was because of that Mac Pro
Stunt but here was the catch to the
whole Mac Pro thing the assembled in USA
Mac Pro was actually made in China for
international customers so basically it
was just a big PR stunt and it worked
and to prove that let me give you a
sneak preview of what's happening with
the upcoming Apple silicon Mac Pro apple
is planning to move Mac Pro production
completely out of the U.S now that Trump
is gone over to Asia but guess what
because of everything that's going on
that I'm going to show you in this video
they are moving it to Vietnam and not
China so luckily Apple was able to dodge
that bullet and everything was working
just fine and successful for the last
couple of years until
2022 where things got a lot more tough
for apple on November 21st Apple
announced that they're extending the
wait time for their popular iPhone 14
models Beyond Christmas as their iPhone
Factory Foxconn scrambles to resume full
production in Zhang Zhao and if you
don't know why that happened well it's
because of another lockdown in China and
because of that there was some bad
protests they are images that rarely
make it out of China open descent
protesters facing off with police at a
factory some have called iPhone City and
that of course put a lot of pressure on
Tim Cook and apple with him in this
video refusing to answer questions on
the Chinese people's right to protest
shutting off airdrop axes in China used
by protesters and iPhone Factory workers
who were beaten and detained for
protesting the lockdowns and then it got
even worse because Market analysts were
lowering their iPhone shipment estimates
based on all of these lockdowns like
Credit Suisse and then another one from
Morgan Stanley cutting their iPhone
production estimate by 3 million units
and of course Apple's stock was taking a
hit over these Chinese protests and then
things took an even worse turn for Apple
because they had to comply with the
Chinese communist government the CCP and
they actually suppressed the protest by
releasing a software update that limited
the use of airdrop in China to slow all
the information down they even removed
apps that helped the protesters track
the police and they banned political
Engravings on its devices in China Hong
Kong and Taiwan so Apple actually had to
help the government out as well and with
everything finally ending on November
30th the lockdown ending it was
estimated that these protests were
costing Apple a billion dollars per week
but the political things got even worse
because in 2021 Apple agreed to
essentially make it an extortion payment
to the Chinese government because of a
five-year deal they made so basically
that payment was to make sure that Apple
would no longer run a foul of various
Chinese economic regulations so Apple
has to Jumble a whole lot of things in
China right now between the communist
government and the factories everything
and the issue is that for many many
years Apple made China the backbone of
its iPhone assembly and shifting away
could take years which is the problem
that they're getting into right now but
guess what just happened on December 3rd
Apple made the announcement that they're
making plans to move production out of
China and this commentary says that
Foxconn must be a heck of a lot worse
than they are telling us to people
saying it's not a big deal they will
move to India everything will be fine
Foxconn manufactured and produced 70 of
Apple's iPhones that is huge you can't
just stop and pack away instantly it's
going to take a lot of time critics say
apple has put itself in a difficult
situation with an extreme dependence on
China as a manufacturer and as a
consumer Market but then the problems
with China got even worse last year in
2022 with all of the political drama and
issues with China and Taiwan with China
reaffirming threat of military force to
Annex Taiwan yes that means take Taiwan
back into the entire state of China and
of course that is hugely controversial
and many people are thinking that an
invasion of Taiwan by China probably
means World War III and even Apple's
chick maker tsmc warned that Taiwan
China war would make everybody losers
and Taiwan even said that a Chinese
attack would hit the global economy
harder than the Ukraine war because tsmc
in Taiwan supplies most of the world's
chips everything comes from Taiwan so if
anything happens that is going to be bad
for the economy so with that said Apple
of course wants to reduce the Reliance
on China and guess what reports we've
been getting over the last few weeks the
iPhone 15 Ultra will not be exclusive
assembled by Foxconn yes Apple's
Flagship will finally start production
elsewhere outside of China which is a
hard thing to do on top of that exports
of iPhones made in India will hit 3
billion dollars as Apple slowly reduces
dependence on China so they're starting
to Outsource more and more into India
and check this out we just got this
piece of News Major iPhone display
supplier is going to build a 250 million
dollar OLED Factory in Vietnam yes
that's actually a Chinese company that's
gonna go out to Vietnam instead of
staying in China and check this out for
the first time ever Foxconn is going to
begin making MacBooks in Vietnam as
early as May
2023 the first time ever getting out of
China and of course we now have the Mac
Pro that is no longer going to be built
in China for the internet National
Market like I mentioned earlier it is
going to Vietnam and finally we have
this chart of Apple's decoupling with
China with the forecast of Apple
products moving away from China for
example about 55 of airpods in China by
2025 it's going to be under 40 percent
the iPhone's going to be under 80
percent iPad 80 Apple watch 80 iPhone
cases are gonna go down 85 percent and
finally MacBooks as well from 100 down
so apple is starting to get out of China
but the question is how long is it going
to take and what's going to happen
between now and then so let me know your
thoughts and comments on this haul
ordeal all of this drama and issues
happening in China let me know down in
the comments section below and if you
want to buy an Apple product that's not
made in China you can use a YouTube
tagging feature right down below thanks
for watching click the circle above for
more more videos like this one and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]